[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit Jana
pareigis herzlich Willkommen an diesem
Samstagabend und mit mir im Studio ist
für den Sport Norbert Lehmann von mir
schauen wir auf die großen
Nachrichtenthemen heute
raketeneinschläge Odessa nur einen Tag
nach dem getreide-deal greift Russland
offenbar gezielt den Hafen an die
Ukraine spricht von einem Bruch des
Abkommens
was wird angesichts der hohen
Energiekosten aus der Schuldenbremse die
Ampelkoalition streitet wie die von
Kanzler Scholz angekündigten
Entlastungen bezahlt werden sollen
und Farbe Weltrekord bei der
Leichtathletik WM als erste Frau läuft
Sydney glockland aus den USA die 400
Meter Hürden unter 51 Sekunden
[Musik]
2 Raketen sind heute in der ukrainischen
schwarzmeermetropole Odessa
eingeschlagen Kiew macht das russische
Militär für den Angriff verantwortlich
Moskau weist das zurück erst gestern
hatten beide Seiten unter der
Vermittlung der UN und der Türkei ein
Abkommen unterzeichnet dass die Ausfuhr
von Getreide per Schiff ermöglichen soll
dabei ist die Hafenstadt Odessa
besonders wichtig weil dort das Getreide
ungeschlagen wird Tobias Hefner über den
150 Kriegstag
Rauchsäulen auf Bildern die den Hafen
von Odessa zeigen sollen veröffentlicht
bei Twitter zwei kaliberraketen laut
Ukraine abgeschossen von Russland seien
dort eingeschlagen wo die
getreideverschiffung stattfindet zwei
weitere Raketen von der Luft Abwehr
abgefangen
das sind teurere Raketen sie werden
nicht oft eingesetzt sie sollen sehr
präzise sein und damit trifft man nur
was man treffen will
getötet oder verletzt wurde demnach
niemand und der materielle Schaden sei
recht gering hieß es dafür ist der
symbolische Schaden um so größer nur
einen Tag ist es her dass in Istanbul
der Vertrag unterzeichnet wurde der
Getreideexporte aus der Ukraine wieder
möglich machen soll
egal was Russland behauptet und
verspricht das Land wird Wege finden das
Abkommen nicht umzusetzen geopolitisch
mit Waffen blutig oder unblutig und
genau deshalb darf auch die Ukraine
nicht am Ende ins Land mit einer
Konfliktlösung nur auf dem Papier
dastehen
auch international ist die Empörung groß
die EU verurteilt den Angriff auf Odessa
schreibt der Außenbeauftragte Borell wer
Infrastruktur für Getreide attackiert
nur einen Tag nach dem Vertrag von
Istanbul zeigt auf verwerfliche Weise
wie egal es einem ist internationales
Recht zu verletzen Moskau hüllt sich
bisher in Schweigen hat sich aber
gegenüber der Türkei geäußert
die Russen sagen dass sie nichts mit der
Attacke zu tun haben sich die Sache aber
genau anschauen
zumindest im Westen wird dem wohl kaum
jemand glauben schenken für die eigene
Bevölkerung setzt Moskau ohnehin weiter
auf Hochglanzbilder von angeblich
chirurgisch präzisen Angriffen auf
militärziele der Beschuss von
lebensmittelanlagen in Odessa passt in
diese kriegsprobaganda nicht
und vor Ort in Odessa ist für uns Sarah
Hassan Sade daran jetzt gab es gerade
diesen Hoffnungsschimmer also durch das
getreideabkommen heute die
Raketenangriffe wie reagieren die
Menschen nur deshalb darauf
ja die Reaktionen sind recht
unterschiedlich ich habe mit einem Mann
gesprochen der sagte einfach lapidar mit
Russland könne man halt keine Abkommen
treffen man verstehe und spreche dort
nur die Sprache der Gewalt ich habe eine
Frau getroffen sie sagte sie saß zur
Mittagszeit auf ihrem Balkon sie sah die
Rakete am Himmel fliegen und auch
einschlagen und sie hat einfach nur
fürchterliche Angst unterschiedlich ist
auch die Reaktion der Behörden wir waren
am Wasser drehen dort wurden die Polizei
Kontrollen massiv verstärkt und wir
mussten auch unseren Dreh abbrechen und
unser Material löschen das kam
eigentlich noch nie vor die Nervosität
ist da wirklich zu spüren andererseits
sagen die Behörden auch dass sie die
Vorbereitungen auf für die Agrarexporte
am Hafen weiterlaufen lassen und
möglichst so schnell wie möglich auch
Schiffe beladen wollen also da versuchen
sie wirklich den Hafen von Odessa was ja
auch der Herzmuskel des Landes ist
zu reanimieren Einschätzungen Eindrücke
auch so dass er Dankeschön Dara Hass
ja Russlands Krieg in der Ukraine lässt
hier die Energie teurer werden Kanzler
Scholz kündigte daher ja gestern weitere
finanzielle Entlastung wie einer
Erhöhung des Wohngeldes an jetzt gibt es
eine Diskussion darüber wie das
finanziert werden soll muss die
Schuldenbremse weiter ausgesetzt bleiben
oder kann sie ab 2023 wieder eingehalten
werden
Sozialverbände lobten die Ankündigung
des Kanzlers aber wünschen sich noch
mehr Unterstützung wird das Spiekermann
Kanzler Scholz schwört gestern die
Deutschen auf noch höhere Preise auf
schwere Zeiten ein helfen soll ein
Rettungsschirm für Bedürftige niemand
werde in der Krise allein gelassen
dass wir gemeinsam die schwierigen
Zeiten bewältigen dass wir
zusammenhalten das ist entscheidend mehr
Wohngeld für mehr Menschen Bürgergeld
schneller einführen mit höheren Sätzen
Kündigungsschutz für finanziell
überforderte Mieterinnen und Mieter es
ist ein großes Paket nicht groß genug
aus Sicht von Sozialverbänden wenn Herr
Scholz ist ernst meint dann müssen die
Regelsätze in Hartz IV und in der
Grundsicherung um 200 Euro monatlich
mindestens erhöht werden und zwar so
schnell wie möglich die FDP trägt die
Vorschläge im Prinzip mit Finanzminister
Lindner warnt aber vor immer neuen
Schulden will die Einhaltung der
Schuldenbremse nächstes Jahr SPD und
Grüne sehen das in der Krise weniger
streng ich finde die Debatte über die
Schuldenbremse falsch weil wir nicht an
der Schuldenbremse das Festmachen
sollten was wir an Politik machen
sondern an der Realität an dem was wir
da draußen sehen und da sehen wir dass
wir in einer außerordentlich schwierigen
Lage sind eine hohe Schuldenlast
vordere aber künftige Generationen sagt
die Union es kommt darauf an
zielgerichtet diejenigen zu unterstützen
die dringend darauf angewiesen sind und
eben auf der anderen Seite auch dafür zu
sorgen dass die Verschuldung des Staates
nicht ins botenlose sich entwickelt
auslaufender Maßnahme Ende August das
9-euro-ticket der Finanzminister sagt
dafür gibt es kein Geld auch Kanzler
Scholz will nicht verlängern über ein
Nachfolgemodell wird verhandelt
eine Notlage internationaler Tragweite
das sei der Ausbruch der affenpocken
erklärt heute die
Weltgesundheitsorganisation WHO und rief
damit die höchste Alarmstufe aus fast
16.000 Fälle in 72 Ländern wurden nach
Angaben der amerikanischen
Gesundheitsbehörde registriert typische
Symptome hohes Fieber geschwollene
Lymphknoten und Pusteln über mögliche
Maßnahmen entscheiden die betroffenen
Länder der gesundheitsnotstand wurde
zuletzt im Januar 2020 wegen Corona
ausgerufen
wie verbreiten sich eigentlich Waffen
Pocken und wie groß ist bei uns die
Gefahr und wie viele affenpockenfälle
gibt es bisher in Deutschland all das
und mehr können Sie in unserer heute App
nachlesen
Temperaturen um die 40 Grad die Menschen
in Südeuropa leiden unter der extremen
Hitze zudem gibt es weiter zahlreiche
heftige Waldbrände
dramatisch die Lage in Italien seit
Wochen herrscht dort extreme Dürre und
auch an der Atlantikküste in Frankreich
oder in Portugal kämpft die Feuerwehr
gegen die Flammen in Spanien ist es
jetzt schon das verheerendste Waldbrand
ja seit Beginn der Erfassungen Thomas
Reichert berichtet
die großen Feuer sind gebannt aber die
Gefahr noch lange nicht in den Bergen
westlich von Madrid wählen die riesigen
Brände im Boden weiter und könnten
jederzeit wieder aufflammen in
Frankreich bei bordeau ist der Boden oft
noch so heiß dass die Feuerwehr
Spiegeleier braten kann
deshalb versuchen sie Brandherde zu
finden und auszutreten
um zu sehen ob es darunter noch brennt
sobald wir irgendwo rauf sehen löschen
wir das indem wir Sand draufschütten
auch in Spanien fliegen die Helikopter
weiter im Kampf gegen die Glut im Boden
fast 200.000 Hektar Wald sind hier in
diesem Jahr schon verbrannt vier Fünftel
der Fläche des Saarlandes
gibt es starke Böen die die heiße Asche
weitertragen und anderswo ein Feuer
entfachen dann fangen wir wieder von
vorne an wir sind immer hinten dran
Satellitenaufnahmen zeigen wie schnell
die Brände in wenigen Tagen riesige
Flächen zerstörten das ist
Südwestfrankreich bei der Düne von Pila
für die Eigentümer des Campingplatzes am
Fuß der Düne ist alles verbrannt die
Saison die Einnahmen ihr Zuhause sie bei
Kühlung das war nicht nur unser
Campingplatz wir lebten hier das
schmerzt dem Herzen das zu sehen
die Regierungen in Frankreich und
Spanien haben wieder Aufforstung
versprochen mehr Einsatz im Kampf gegen
den Klimawandel es bleibt erstmal ein
Versprechen
und eine weitere Folge der Hitze unter
Trockenheit in Europa Niedrigwasser in
unseren Flüssen wie am Rhein zum
Beispiel dabei ist der ein wichtiger
Transportweg für güterwegetreidekohle
oder Benzin so wenig Wasser das
beeinträchtigt die Frachtschifffahrt und
damit auch die Wirtschaft mehr von Ansem
Stern
wie wenig Wasser da ist wie sehr die
Trockenheit schadet das sieht man ganz
besonders hier am Rhein in der Nähe von
Koblenz Kaub in Rheinland-Pfalz ein
wichtiges Nadelöhr für viele waren die
Schiffe sind unterwegs aber nur mit
halber Ladung oder weniger mehr geht
nicht der Fluss ist nicht mehr tief
genug am Ende des Tages muss jemand
bezahlen die Binnenschifffahrt selber
bekommt ein Ausgleich für diese
minderabladung aber die Befrachtung wird
eigentlich teurer für den Kunden und
somit auch für den Endverbraucher und
das ist eigentlich nicht gut schlechte
Nachrichten also beim Thema Preise schon
wieder und die Nachfrage steigt wegen
der schwierigen gaslage wird mehr Kohle
bestellt und einige Schiffe die
eigentlich in Deutschland fahren
transportieren aktuell Weizen aus der
Ukraine durch Europa
jeder sucht verzweifelt nach Schiffsraum
alle Schiffe sind in Fahrt wir haben
nicht mehr
Verunsicherung löst das aus bei der
Industrie die Lage könne sich schnell
zuspitzen heißt es die Konzerne etwa aus
der Chemiebranche brauchen regelmäßige
Lieferungen unbedingt wir haben
logistikprobleme nicht nur auf dem
Binnenschiff sondern auch auf der
Schiene und auf der Straße Fahrermangel
sind ist ein Stichwort
Baustellenmanagement bei der Bahn ist
ein anderes Stichwort wo es hapert dazu
ist die Unsicherheiten was
Energielieferungen anbetrifft Stichwort
Erdgas das alles macht das stimmt und
sehr besorgt Wirtschaft und Fachleute
fordern Investitionen von der Politik
etwa Zuschüsse für neue teure sogenannte
niedrigwasserschiffe außerdem müssten
Fahrrinnen besser ausgebaut werden denn
die Trockenheit könnte in Zukunft noch
heftiger werden
fast ganz Deutschland hat jetzt Ferien
bis auf Bayern und Baden-Württemberg
viele sind jetzt auf dem Weg in den
Urlaub oder fahren schon wieder zurück
der ADAC warnte vor einem der
staureichsten Wochenende was auf den
Straßen und Flughäfen los war dazu
Clemens Altmann
auch auf der A2 zwischen Bielefeld und
Hannover staute sich der Verkehr vor
einer Baustelle auf 11 km für die
Reisenden ein Zeitverlust von mehr als
zwei Stunden
insgesamt sehen wir für diesen
reisesommer oder generell für diese
reisere Saison ein Stau Niveau wie wir
es 2019 also vor der corona-pandemie
hatten die stauknotenpunkte liegen vor
allem da wo es in Richtung Urlaub geht
also nach Österreich und weiter nach
Italien in Richtung Niederlande aber
auch zur Nord- und Ostsee auf der A7
besteht fast durchgehend in beide
Richtungen Staugefahr
lange Wartezeiten auch auf den Flughäfen
wie hier in Frankfurt am Main fehlendes
Personal lässt die Schlangen vor den
Countern anwachsen Verspätungen sind an
der Tagesordnung ja wer vertrauen darauf
dass das Flugzeug wartet habe ich das
für recht vorne in der Schlange sind
mache ich mir jetzt keine großen Sorgen
aber ich glaube die Kollegen haben
vielleicht ein anderes Gefühl also wir
haben noch eine Stunde Zeit bis zum Flug
ungefähr
wir hoffen dass es klappt
auf den Autobahnen versuchen stauhelfer
der Johanniter den Unmut der Reisenden
aufzufangen die wenigsten reagieren da
relativ locker das kann man aber
natürlich auch verstehen der reisedruck
ist hoch das Zimmer wartet die Fähre
wartet oder dergleichen also da ist
schon immer teilweise auch eine gereizte
Stimmung der ADAC rechnet auch am
Sonntag mit längeren Staus vor allem vor
den Autobahn Baustellen und davon gibt
es in Deutschland aktuell über 900
laut und bunt seit 44 Jahren pflegen
berliner:innen diese Tradition im Kampf
gegen Benachteiligung und die heißt
Christopher Street Day
quasi ein politischer Feiertag für alle
die sich zur lesbischen schwulen
bisexuellen Trans intergeschlechtlichen
und queren Community zählen die Bewegung
begannen als New Yorker Polizisten im
Juni 1969 eine Bahn der Christopher
Street stürmten und so einen Aufstand
auslösten von Schwulen Lesben und
Menschen die Trans sind über den CSD in
Berlin Sebastian Orlowski
das hier ist keine Parade darauf wie ist
der Berliner CSD e.V als Veranstalter
von Anfang an hin Bund und laut ja aber
es soll eine Demonstration sein mit
klarer politischer Botschaft das ist
eigentlich die hauptmessage united in
Love vereint in Liebe ein Europa eine
Welt die versucht eben gegen Hass und
gegen Krieg und gegen Diskriminierung
vorzugehen als deutliches politisches
Zeichen weht seit heute morgen die
Regenbogenflagge zum ersten Mal
überhaupt auch über dem
Reichstagsgebäude als Unterstützung aber
auch als Mahnung dass auf der Welt in
Europa und in Deutschland Anfeindungen
gegenüberqueren Menschen immer noch
Realität sind
die täglichen Diskriminierungen die
täglichen Attacken vergangenes Jahr am
Rande des CSD gab es in Überfall auf auf
quiers ein 21-jähriger Mann wurde schwer
verletzt also es gibt noch genug zu tun
insofern geht hier vor allem hoffe ich
ein kämpferisches Signal von aus ein
Signal für das heute mehr als 150.000
Menschen in Berlin auf die Straße
gegangen sind
was man liebt das einfach alle gleich
behandelt werden es ist ein super Gefühl
hier zu sein so viele Leute zu sehen die
selber so sind wie man selbst und die
zusammen mit Liebe und Gute Laune gegen
Hass und Gewalt einstehen
nun kommen wir zum Sport zur
frauenfußball-em in England Norbert
heute das letzte Viertelfinale
Frankreich gegen die Niederlande und da
entscheidet sich ja auch gegen wen die
DFB-Elf am Mittwoch im Halbfinale
antritt le bleu sind bei allen großen
Turnieren spätestens im Viertelfinale
ausgeschieden oranie ist der
Titelverteidiger Lena Kesting in
rotterham ja wer ist denn da nur der
Favorit
[Musik]
das ist eine wirklich schwierige Frage
Norbert und richtig werden wir das erst
nach Apfel vier wissen denn da treffen
wirklich zwei Mannschaften auf Augenhöhe
aufeinander da sieht man auch wenn man
sich die FIFA Weltrangliste anguckt das
ist heute Platz drei gegen Platz 4 die
Französinnen du hast das angesprochen
die wollen endlich diesen Fluch der
letzten achtlos werden und es bei einer
Euro weiter schaffen die Niederländerin
die haben wieder Verstärkung bekommen
denn Stürmerinnen Vivien medema ist
wieder bei der Mannschaft die war ja
Corona positiv muss dann Isolation
musste sogar ihren Geburtstag hier in
England in Isolation feiern jetzt war
sie gestern beim Training aber wieder
mit dabei und nach allem was wir hier
aus der niederländischen Mannschaft
hören sieht es gut aus dass sie heute
tatsächlich auch mit von der Partie sein
wird also so oder so ich glaube ich
lehne mich nicht zu weit aus dem Fenster
wenn ich sage das wird spannend heute
Abend und alle Zuschauerinnen und
Zuschauer die mit dabei sein wollen die
können das ab 20 Uhr bei uns hier im ZDF
danke Lena
ja und dem dritten Viertelfinale gestern
Abend da setzte sich Schweden denkbar
knapp durch gegen Belgien und zwar durch
ein Last-Minute von Linda sembrandt in
der Nachspielzeit die Skandinavierinnen
spielbestimmend die Belgien hielten 92
Minuten leidenschaftlich und kämpferisch
dagegen Schweden trifft am Dienstag im
Halbfinale auf England
Vorletzter Tag der Tour de France und da
hat der belgier-fan Art das Einzelzeit
fern gewonnen der dene Jonas vinegar
wurde Zweiter verteidigt sein Gelbes
Trikot und dürfte damit morgen in Paris
die Tour gewinnen
emotionaler familiärer Empfang für Jonas
wingegor der dänisch steht unmittelbar
vor seinem ersten Gesamtsieg bei der
Tour de France mehr als drei Minuten
sein Vorsprung vor dem Zeitfahren von La
Capell maribal nach roccarbadur
zweieinhalb Kilometer vor der Ziellinie
kommt wingelcoa fast von der Straße ab
übersteht die Schrecksekunde jedoch und
schließt die 20 Etappe als zweiter ab
noch schneller nur sein Teamkollege baut
von Art bester Deutscher Maximilian
schachmann auf Platz 9 im gelben Trikot
geht es für winkelgor morgen auf die
letzte Etappe nach Paris bei der
traditionell nicht mehr attackiert wird
startet morgen beim Großen Preis von
Frankreich von der Poleposition danke
Unterstützung seines Teamkollegens
Carlos science vor der montegasse
souverän auf den ersten Platz dahinter
Weltmeister Max Förster und Sergio Paris
beide im Red Bull Sebastian Vettel wurde
Olympiasiegerin Sydney Mac Login aus den
USA hat sich mit dem ersten Weltrekord
der Leichtathletik WM in Eugene den
Titel über die 400 Meter Hürden
gesichert die 22-Jährige unter Boot in
unglaublichen
50,68 Sekunden ihre vier Wochen zuvor an
gleicher Stelle erzielte Bestmarke um
gleich 73 Hundertstel Silber ging an die
Niederländerin ferngeball vor
titelverteidigen die leider Mohammed aus
den USA
ja Deutschland bislang ohne Medaille
aber jetzt startet der Zehnkampf zu
sehen im Livestream bei sportstudio.de
Dankeschön und wir werden noch einen
kurzen Blick aufs Wetter morgen ist es
oft sonnig im nordendichter bewölkt aber
kaum Regen und ganz genau erfahren Sie
es gleich von Christa Orden und in der
Halbzeitpause des Frauen
em-viertelfinales können Sie um etwa
21:50 Uhr das heute journal sehen mit
Wolf schmieser tschüss bis morgen
[Musik]
guten Abend uns erwartet morgen einen
sonniger Tag den Norden Streifen
allerdings die Wolken einer Warmfront
von tief Daniela da hinten dahinter
folgt dann morgen und übermorgen diese
heiße Luft aus dem Südwesten die wird
allerdings auch schnell von der
Kaltfront des gleichen Tiefs wieder
ausgeräumt heute Nacht ist es am
mildesten im Süden mit 14 bis 17 Grad im
Norden und den Mittelgebirgen ist es mit
8 bis 14 Grad kühler ganz im Norden
haben wir in der Nacht auch noch einige
Wolken in der Mitte ist es klar im Süden
anfangs noch letzte Gewitter die Klingen
dann aber ab und morgen haben wir dann
hier nur noch lockere Quellwolken
insgesamt ist es in der Mitte und im
Süden oft wolkenlos von der Nordsee her
verdichten sich aber die Wolken das ist
dann eben diese Warmfront die aber wohl
kaum Regen bringt der Wind dreht
allerdings auf südliche Richtungen und
damit wird der Weg frei für die heiße
Mittelmeerluft das ist morgen schon
deutlich wärmer als heute um 25 Grad an
den Küsten und 33 Grad in Mittelfranken
am da gibt es dann 36 Grad aber nur im
Südosten denn von Nordwesten her da
kommen schon diese Kaltfront hoffentlich
mit etwas regenwohl aber wieder mit
Gewittern die kühlt dann am Dienstag und
am Mittwoch wieder ab auf angenehme 18
bis 28 Grad am Dienstag können wir dazu
wohl noch ein bisschen Regen abstauben
am Mittwoch haben wir ein trockenes
Sonne wolken-mix das war es von uns das
wetterteam wünscht noch einen schönen
Abend